an influential taliban cleric has been
killed in a suicide attack in
afghanistan witnesses say a disabled man
approached rohimalahakani in a seminary
in kabul he then detonated explosives
hidden in his prosthetic leg
samba binch of eight has more from kabul
sheikh rahimullah
was considered to be somebody very
influential and loved by both leaders
and followers of the taliban somebody
who was able to gather them together
on various religious issues he'd been
issuing decrees against isil and was
attacked by the group at least twice
before he was killed in kabul when a
suicide bomber wearing a prosthetic leg
approached him and explosives were
hidden inside that prosthetic leg his
brother was also injured in the attack
he was somebody who was
able to bring together various factions
of the taliban and make sure that they
were following a single line and that's
why his
death will be seen as a blow to
especially the theological side of
taliban it also comes
and bears all the hallmarks of isil
related attacks that we've seen in the
last few months in this country although
no group claimed responsibility so far
but we were in isil heartland uh just 24
hours ago and we were able to speak to
people as well as security officials
there who tell us that yes there had
been an isil resurgence in the early
days when the taliban took over last
year but the group has been able to
crack down on isil remnants go after
their sleeper cells and infiltrate
their intelligence has been able to
infiltrate isil as well but isil
continues to have
wield the presence in this country has
been carrying out attacks against
mosques and other places as well and the
taliban were saying that their biggest
achievement so far in this country has
been able to provide security to the
people of afghanistan and definitely
attacks such as this one and previous
ones which have been claimed by isil are
meant to dent that